the audio on because I have really
important things to say and we're over
it boy just a helpless helpless human
raggle at your service
hi guys Republic did I know that you
know you're just different now it's
Monday I got to make a video for you so
I thought let's answer some questions
let's meet me and my fabulous hairstyle
I went on my Facebook page cuz yeah I
have a Facebook page
surprise I don't use it hardly ever but
do I own it yes it's like my shower I
went on there and asked you guys to send
me some cues like an A so let's do that
cash the goons come with her name or did
you pick it juice did not come with her
name her name was Phoenix when I got her
a Phoenix is just farted mythical
magical name for this thing so I would
do
boobs like the animal which is a dumb
atom on my opinion and goose like the
verb to squeeze a booty what are some of
the pros of an adult you can come home
bro drunk and just take a block of vegan
cheese with you into your bed and eat it
like an apple and that's totally legal
is it attractive absolutely not
but legal yeah hey you coming to Europe
this year yes I'm going to VidCon
Amsterdam will any of you be there wow
that sounds fun cool great yeah what
does goose have to say about the trip
since they're very emotional what is
your favorite part about being a
youtuber you can come home really drunk
seeing a block of vegan cheese on your
refrigerator take it into bed with you
and eat it like an apple and then the
next day you didn't turn a camera on and
tell that to do you pull what's your
favorite foundation at the moment oh let
me get visuals any visual aids
I'm a big fan of Kat Von D's locket
foundation it's got an amazing amazing
coverage and it lasts all day long
awesome Marc Jacobs remarkable
combination was also has amazing full
coverage and feels like you're way
nothing on your face but this is kind of
expensive so I don't use this all time
only for nice occasions like going to
the glows others or to dubbing to be raw
just when I'm about to go in a couple
hours I have a life of glamour tomorrow
my first ever drop in to do any advice
go fish yourself or yourself don't puke
all over anyone or yourself sanyas
racial slurs pretty easy four-step plan
what I going to do after I graduate my
form a get a life Madison literally you
will have to start making decisions on
life which will be dangerous and making
it any more real how do you do
occasional depression 3:10 it is a very
hard to play neutral instrument just by
testing it which would you choose and
why I already do not playing a bunch
with just touching it the skin flute low
that's gross my pair software videos
should have taken this out do you have
any fictional character on not to be
booted b-squared wallow and the first
question out asking is what are you
running and where do you buy your
scriptures because I love them how do
you feel getting hate in the comments
feels like it would be hard emotionally
it is very difficult but don't let
haters get you down instead take your
emotional response to haters even though
they might be saying pretty true cutting
things about you and just put that down
deep inside of your emotional body cave
and then let it manifest itself at some
other point your life is wildly
unhealthy and not deserving at any of
the people that are around me with a
moment or therapy when it connects your
consciousness videos you gather them or
they happen whether you like it they're
random you can't plug up those dreams
when they're coming what I've been
thinking about doing more live streams
on YouTube that would essentially be a
stream of consciousness a live stream of
consciousness what if we do that unlike
a weekly bi-weekly basis you guys be
intimate there's no actual promises here
this is just presenting ideas of things
that might happen while being
consistently throughout the future
time here leaf of Commerce what are you
doing in your free time I also do silly
Bailey
yes mr. lee Bailey but my body has kind
of a negative reaction to the cream what
am i doing in my free time I'm just
experiencing a culture
[Music]
do you miss his TV show would you
consider something like that again
I still miss the TV show sometimes but
it was a wonderful experience and I'm
glad that I had that full moment in time
with it I would like to do TV again but
in maybe not talk to y'all capacity I
don't know
can I come out to my grandma yeah and
only your grandma repeatedly she seems
like a kind of woman it like that she
doesn't want you to pursue forever who
would it be
my immediate response to this is Joe
sugg I think you feeling real adorable
but what any other one get that mad be
fun if you have to have one object with
your left hand for the rest of your life
what would be dry it up do any youtube
if you watch regularly I watched panel
are made my heart from outside their
windows of their home pretty regularly
until the Franco TV make them myself
i watch just salient light on the
regular basis if you had a pectus what
we came it dog will comics channel
comments ever come back maybe also maybe
how do you manage your stress love you
just a classic repressed manifest cycle
of torture f develop myself which is due
to damage in the benefits of stuff we
wisdom yet some other boy in your life
that should it be there before how does
it go be 31 how does it feel to be
someone that cares about how someone
feels about their age it feels great to
be 31
I'm having a great time with it I'm very
excited I loved hearing that I'm 31
you've got another it will touch you on
your last drunken night out what do you
think it would have been aware got
morning Tyler Oakley and mamrie Hart and
my face as Mount Rushmore on my lower
back
why was that going to touch you I don't
know based on my last junket outing
okay that's it for this Q&A hope you
guys enjoyed it if you liked Q&A
sandworm using more of them comment let
me know and if you like this video at
all and want to see more of them on a
regular basis by getting notifications
of things subscribe to this YouTube
channel enter my notifications on so
you'll know when videos get uploaded
because it's really random named a very
inconsistent and I'll fun of that like a
little surprise every time that your
expectations yes miss when they should
always get met but not here I don't know
do more of my videos I have fun watching
you the other night Gracie was seriously
underrated and funny app thank you for
making videos my friend and I love
laughing pan and watching your content
that is so nice Jessica and also not a
fitting question so play by the rules
I'm kidding kind of that's very sweet of
you please to never stop watching and
please never break up with your
boyfriend because she seems like a
quality dude got a great taste it was